harp deep in the wilds of Alaska as a
secretive military research program
called ha which stands for high
frequency active auroral research
program the facility consists of an
antenna array made up of 360
transmitters this giant array shoots
high power radiofrequency beams into the
atmosphere or ionosphere some speculate
heart is capable of emitting a signal
that has billions of watts in power
HAARP can literally move the atmosphere
and create holes in it miles across part
has the power to modify the weather
many believe HAARP is to blame for a
range of natural disasters around the
world including floods droughts
hurricanes thunderstorms and even
earthquakes and it can create
earthquakes at any point on the earth by
manipulating the magnetosphere
conspiracists believe HAARP is to blame
for the recent disasters in Haiti and
Japan some even believe that HAARP has
developed the ability to mind-control
entire populations of people by emitting
extremely low frequency waves adjusting
their mental state the world is run by
lizards English author and ex BBC
reporter David Icke wrote a series of
books detailing how the world's most
powerful individuals are actually
shape-shifting reptilians belonging to
an ancient race of omnipotent lizard
people according to acts conspiracy
George Bush and even the entire British
royal family are actually reptilian
lizard people yeah this is widely
regarded as one of the least believable
conspiracy theories yet 12.5 million
Americans genuinely believe the world is
run by lizard people the new world order
a staggering 28 percent of Americans
believe in some kind of new world order
in this new world order the world will
be ruled by a single global
following a mass genocide obviously this
opposing new government is currently
being built behind the scenes by a group
of secretive power elite individuals and
has been for centuries the most well
known new world order conspiracy is the
Illuminati the Illuminati is an ancient
group of am nipa tantalise who control
every aspect of global affairs from
behind the scenes such as governments
religion and even culture supposed
members of the Illuminati includes
Barack Obama the Pope queen elizabeth ii
george w bush jay-z bob dylan beyonce
lady gaga and even jim carrey after all
he is god but this is just a small
selection of the hundreds of important
figures who are supposed members of the
secret society but wait there's more the
Illuminati is made up of devil
worshipping antichrists yeah when he
joined the Illuminati you have to sell
your soul to the devil if you try and
leave the Illuminati you are
assassinated hence Michael Jackson and
many other mysterious celebrity deaths
Denver Airport is a portal to Hell also
you would think so looking at the decor
well that's not how the fever goes
many believe that Denver International
Airport is supposedly home to the
world's largest underground bunker or
city situated right underneath the
airport the bunker or city is said to
house the world's most important figures
aka the Illuminati in Coke in the event
of a global disaster such as a nuclear
war but then they used to have a
perfectly adequate airport located only
six miles from Denver but everyone was
extremely content with nevertheless a
new airport was built in 1995 for no
apparent reason there was absolutely
nothing wrong with the previous airport
the new airport covers 53 square miles
which is twice the size of Manhattan the
airport was commissioned at the cost of
1.7 billion dollars but it was finished
two years late
and 3.1 billion dollars over budget
because that's normal but this is where
it gets weird the airport was privately
funded but nobody knows by whom there's
a very creepy stone in the airport which
reads funded by the New World Airport
Commission guess what the New World
Airport Commission doesn't exist there
were bloody creepy murals all over the
airport depicting scenes of mass
destruction murder and general but times
this one in particular shows a shadowy
figure wielding a scimitar and ak-47
stabbing a dog to death which is a
symbol for peace nice he is emanating a
wave of gray smoke killing everything
and everyone in its path that is one
seriously messed up painting the airport
is also filled with disturbing decor
such as a gargoyle coming out of a
suitcase and yeah because nothing says
we'll look after your baggage better
than a gargoyle if all that's not enough
to welcome you home how about a satanic
red-eyed horse at the entrance
the sculptures artist Luis Jimenez
actually died whilst creating it when
its head fell on him we know there is
some sort of large underground structure
beneath the airport because five
buildings were ordered to be buried
underneath the airport during its
construction but nobody knows how deep
the rabbit-hole actually goes in 2011
when a comet known as Elenin narrowly
missed colliding with earth
President Obama was conveniently
Worcester to Denver in time to be
sheltered from what would have been an
apocalyptic event if it had hit if that
doesn't scream suspicion I don't know
what does hidden oil reserves many
believe there are huge oil and gas
reserves around the world kept secret by
the US government uncertain nefarious
individuals the media keep telling us we
are running out of oil to create false
scarcity and keep fuel prices high
whereas we actually have access to oil
in abundance maybe they're saving it so
a lot for the New World Order
chemtrails 15.6 million Americans
believe in a conspiracy called
chemtrails shorts for chemical trails
they believe the pretty white streaks
last June across the sky when an
aeroplane passes overhead actually
contain copious amounts of harmful
chemicals conspiracists believe these
chemicals which of course are put there
by the government have the potential to
be used for all kinds of nefarious deeds
for spreading diseases all the waiting
man control and geoengineering age was
created by the CIA
ever since 1981 when the media first
reported the AIDS pandemic many believed
the disease was created in a lab by the
CIA to wipe out homosexuals and African
Americans charming conspiracists
believed that the disease was
deliberately injected into homosexuals
during the hepatitis B experiments in
San Francisco Los Angeles and New York
during 1978 please note this video
should not be taken seriously it is
purely for entertainment purposes and I
am not endorsing any of the
aforementioned conspiracy theories thank
you so much for watching please leave a
comment below and let me know what you
want me to do next time subscribe if you
haven't already and I'll see you next
time bye bye